it's late afternoon on a warm winter day
in 1978 and South Korean actress Choi
unhi is walking along a secluded beach
in Hong Kong 40 feet away a woman she
knows stands on the shore motioning her
to come over a few strong-looking men
stand by her side Choi feels uneasy like
something bad is about to happen and
she's right she's been lured here as
Choi walks over to the woman a speedboat
filled with more strong-looking men
pulls up to the shore the men watch as
Choi approaches and when she gets near
they nodded each other they grab her and
they force her into the boat their
destination
North Korea
[Music]
Choi was kidnapped to be forced to star
in movies for the North Korean leader
Kim Jong-il
this is a story about film and Cinema in
the scariest country on Earth but really
this is about a Storyteller Kim Jong-il
the second leader of North Korea a man
who could change the weather with his
mood and who invented the hamburger in
the year 2000 even though it had already
been invented and one thing about
jung-il is that he loved movies
he used the art and craft of Cinema not
only as a tool to indulge his own
creative dreams but also as a way to
drill his propaganda into the minds of
millions of North Koreans to hold on to
power cementing him and his family as
the powerful Leaders of North Korea
hey before we go on did you know that
there is a market of people and
companies that do everything in their
power to know more about you about your
birthday about your address about your
online activity about your preferences
so that they can take that and sell it
on an open market to corporations that
want to Market to you I hate that it's
gotten so out of control my email inbox
is a mess my phone is always ringing and
it's most of the time it's robots I am
done with this luckily there exists a
solution and that solution happens to be
the sponsor of today's video thank you
incogni incogni is a service that takes
you off of these lists which is not an
easy thing actually a few years ago I
tried to unsubscribe myself like I tried
to go through this process and I
actually failed like I could not do it
luckily incognate exists so the way it
works is you sign up and you give
Incognito permission to reach out to
data Brokers on your behalf to exercise
your rights to not be on these lists
like you all have a right to do this but
the process is so complicated the the
number of data Brokers is so great that
none of us will actually unsubscribe
from these lists incognate deletes
personal information from dozens of data
Brokers I've been on incognate
monitoring the progress and I am very
pleased with what I am seeing I'm
getting taken off these lists left and
right I am on my journey to be rid of
all of this spam and that is a very
satisfying reality so you can get this
at a massive discount at least if you're
click the link in my description which
is incognito.com Johnny Harris you can
go sign up and get 60 off incogni it
gets a huge discount and start your
journey of getting rid of your personal
information from all of these
marketplaces what you're paying for is
privacy and cogni is here to help
protect us from what has become a very
malicious industry of data Brokers thank
you incogni for existing and for
sponsoring today's video let's get back
to Kim Jong-il and all of his wild
shenanigans oh
[Music]
we watched as many North Korean films as
we could get our hands on to make this
video and let me tell you this is a
world of Cinema unlike anything you've
ever seen it's one full of farmer
revolutions and extreme nationalism and
women frequently sacrificing their lives
as well as a lot of music spontaneous
Odes to the great leader and some really
colorful operas
foreign
so I want to let you into this world and
show you how this happened how this one
man's Obsession drove him to literally
kidnap people in the name of making
movies movies that he used to brainwash
his people but also movies that he hoped
would help fulfill his dream of turning
North Korea into a center of world-class
Cinema
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
log cabin and shrouded in dense
snow-capped forest the great leader
opened his eyes for the very first time
the thunderous rain stilled the dark
clouds parted and threw them a
glimmering double rainbow emerged
arching its way across the muted morning
sky and a bright new star appeared
overhead making its debut in the Open
Heavens The Shining Star of pectu had
arrived well at least that's the story
that most North Koreans were told in
reality the year was actually 1941.
likely at some Soviet military base in
Russia there probably weren't any
rainbows or new stars created it's
probably just a normal day oh and his
given name wasn't even Kim Jong-il it
was Yuri ilsenovich Kim
right that's like a total Russian name
as an adult he rewrote his backstory
again and again over the course of like
20 years and this is our first big clue
about Kim Jong-il the second leader of
North Korea he was a storyteller
the legend goes that when he was seven
years old he was watching this North
Korean film called my home Village he
was with his parents and after the movie
This seven-year-old Zhang IL marched up
to one of the filmmakers and told him
that the winter scene in the movie
didn't feel lifelike because the falling
snow wasn't actually collecting on the
character's head like it didn't look
natural and instead it looked like what
it actually was which was cotton balls
totally low budget and unacceptable the
filmmakers were so ashamed that they
reshot the scene without the falling
snow and re-released the film jong-il's
obsession with movies grew over time
till he eventually collected 20 000
bootlegged VHS and DVDs that were stored
in an air-conditioned Library manned
with 250 full-time employees like this
guy was serious about his movies and he
would watch these movies like all the
time everything from Hollywood westerns
to Classics like Friday the 13th and
Rambo to Japanese in these monster
movies like Godzilla he was a big fan of
American stars like Elizabeth Taylor and
he apparently loved Daffy Duck and the
James Bond franchise well that is until
a Bond film came out where North Korean
leaders were like the enemies he was
actually pretty insulted with that one
but this guy was a full-blown xenophile
like he watched so many movies that his
dad Kim il-sung the founder of North
Korea was actually pretty concerned that
his obsession had become unhealthy but
soon Kim jong-il's dictator dad would
find a way to use his son's Obsession to
stay in power
okay so this story is kind of nuts it's
1967. North Korea is still kind of a
newish country like a couple decades old
Kim jong-il's dad is still the leader
dictator who's running the country has
all the power but he's got competition
from other powerful people within the
party that want him to step aside and
make way for a new leader these men want
to steer North Korea in a New Direction
by choosing their own successor to him
and this competing faction starts to use
film as a tool to get the people of
North Korea on board they make a movie
celebrating the life of this aspiring
successor trying to lay a groundwork for
a new cult of personality around this
guy not Kim il-sung big mistake Kim
il-sung's not gonna let this happen he
goes straight to his Film Studio in the
capital Pyongyang and he gives a speech
he warns the whole film department that
someone in the party is trying to
glorify themselves which is super not
communist and they're using film to do
it so Kim says to all of his filmmakers
we need to step up our game in securing
power through film and then he asks if
any anyone has the courage to guide the
film studio correctly meaning to make
more effective propaganda that will keep
Kim il-sung and his family in power oh
and look who's in the room film buff and
Son of the dictator Kim Jong-il The
Shining Star he's watching quietly in
the back of the room and then he speaks
up saying that he would nobody volunteer
to be the head of the film studio to
help level up North Korean Cinema to
help hold on to power
something must have clicked for Kindle
sung at that moment his son who was not
a promising candidate for his successor
he was helplessly obsessed with movies
but here he is stepping up finally
passionate about politics because
politics and film are now kind of the
same thing it was clear that if there
was any position that he would fit into
this was it so he promotes his son on
the spot to lead the propaganda and
agitation Department the department in
charge of all movies plays and
Publishing within North Korea retelling
this story of North Korea to its people
reframing it as something glorious
keeping the people indoctrinated to the
version of reality that keeps the Kims
in power and using film to do it the
struggle for the future of North Korea
was happening on the Silver Screen and
now Jung IL had his hand on the dial in
control of what he called this powerful
ideological weapon
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
getting into the mind of an artist can
be hard
but in this case not really
if there's one thing Kim Jong-il like to
do it was the talk about his thoughts on
Cinema he wrote an entire book about it
which was kind of the impetus of this
entire video This Book
on the art of cinema by Kim Jong-il when
I was hanging out at the North Korean
border last year I had this book with me
and I would like read it in between
stops and it's actually kind of good at
least parts of it like a lot of it's
like garbage but like there are parks
that actually like I was like oh yeah
you got this like this is basically the
Holy Bible of North Korean filmmaking
and it dictates how movies in the
country should be made
I mean the book spends a lot of time
making it crystal clear that filmmakers
are an extension of the government and
they are charged with the noble task of
leading the ideological Revolution via
storytelling devoting their artistic
skill to the party's Endeavor to build
socialism and communism in other words
filmmaker's job is to make clever
propaganda for its people this isn't
unique to North Korea since the
invention of the motion picture
governments of all kinds have used the
power of Cinema to tell their story in
their way often sugar-coated often
inaccurate to the facts but I'm telling
you North Korean Cinema has its own
weird wild flavor
[Music]
foreign
this is the great age of chuche
chuche is the foundational ideology of
North Korea it has its foundation in
Marxist communism like from the Soviet
Union but it has an obsessive focus on
isolation and self-reliance and it
glorifies independence from Outsiders in
this book Kim Jong-il makes it very
clear that to make a successful North
Korean film that characters should quote
live work and struggle with the
conviction that they are masters of the
Revolution and the work of socialist
construction a lot of clunky language
here I'm not sure if it's just a bad
translation or if Kim Jong-il is just a
really writer anyway it goes on to say
that the characters in these films
should accept the full responsibility of
solving their own problems without any
outside help
come on
you can see this obsession with
self-reliance in this movie called
myself in the distant future there's a
scene where this tractor is like plowing
a field and it breaks down but it's not
a problem for these good communist
Farmers look what happens next they step
up they pull out their sickles and they
harvest the rest of the field by hand
with smiles on their faces they don't
need Outsider technology from the big
city to make their lives easier they're
self-reliant oh and right before this
scene all of these Farmers had just
broken out into spontaneous poetry
chanting about dedicating their lives to
North Korea during this like Poetic
chanting there's just like shots of
Mount pet too really nice b-roll not
because it has anything to do with the
story but just so we remember like not
pectu is like super important because
that's where Kim Jong-il was born anyway
he really wasn't born
laughs
another big theme is struggle in the
book he quotes his beloved father Kim
il-sung quote the life of a
revolutionary begins with struggle and
ends with struggle this is really good
propaganda because you've got juche and
struggle as like the foundational
ingredients you start to see stories
that glorify and give meaning to North
Koreans suffering like this 1989 film
called the broad Bellflower sort of a
love story where Like This Woman's lover
like gets exiled from the town and
there's this tension on whether or not
she should leave her hometown for a
different life and then the father of
the main character comments very wisely
that it's actually better to stay and
struggle to find happiness like
glorifying the struggle and in case it
didn't come through the first time near
the end of the movie the main character
finds out that her lover is trying to
come back to the hometown that he
deserted and she's confirmed on how
right her father was struggle is the
only way to achieve happiness
foreign
[Music]
so now all over North Korea you have
starving people cut off from the world
economy because of their despotic leader
watching these movies stories about how
it's actually the most noble way to live
the key to happiness the noble ideals of
self-reliance the regime made sure that
everyone saw these films way out in the
countryside in factories Farms Army
units and all of this helped North
Korean citizens reframe their country's
Reckless dictatorship into a protector
of an eternal Revolution that must
continue to fight against outside evil
there's a whole chapter in this book
that Kim Jong-il writes to screenwriters
he tells them to think of their stories
as seeds again this is actually like
pretty profound if not applied to
propaganda he tells these screenwriters
that they need to quote equip themselves
with the ideology of the party
translation choose stories that will
stick in people's minds that will grow
that will turn these people's suffering
into fuel for North Korean nationalism
and pride pride in the country that's
causing the suffering in the first place
there's one movie where this football
player trains ridiculously hard all in
the name of quote achieving the
teachings of the fatherly leader Kim
il-sung to turn North Korea into a
kingdom of sports
foreign
[Music]
these nationalistic pump up movies pair
nicely with films that rewrite the story
of North Korea the history the story of
Japanese Occupation of the Korean
Peninsula which was indeed brutal and
deserves to be told accurately because
it was bad enough but these movies just
like so overly caricatures glorifying
the revolution against capitalists and
landlords or showing these caricatured
battle scenes where the Koreans defeat
the Japanese in a good old flying
martial arts scene
and while these ideologies and these
messages are kind of baked into the
story oftentimes they're just sort of
shoehorned in in the form of like a
music break were these characters just
sort of randomly burst into songs about
how their struggle is good for the
future of their country
la la la la
la la la la la la la la la
these unwarranted music moments are
everywhere in North Korean films in this
chapter he says that these films must
have music that has revolutionary
passion that moves people to strive to
defend what is new and Noble
[Music]
he says that songs should be short
simple easy to understand and to sing
infectious catchy so that people will
sing along and get it stuck in their
head
[Music]
okay so in watching all of these movies
we were surprised that these films give
a surprisingly significant role to women
[Music]
so this is actually a feature of a lot
of communist propaganda which she's
traditional female roles as in line with
the ideals of like a model communist
comrade submissive identities being
determined by their relationship to the
family to their communities in this case
and most importantly to the state
community-minded submission Stalin
actually used the same trick back in the
30s creating art that appealed to quote
the feminine identification and
submission so you see this in North
Korean films like in this film girls
from my hometown where the main
character is this country girl who shows
her dedication to her country by
pledging to take care of her husband
who's newly blinded after coming back
from a war as an act of sacrifice for
her country
foreign
in this film called the name given by
the era the main character gives up
going to college to lead a construction
and take on the grueling task of
building a
damage
why because hard work and struggle
benefit the country and that is the most
important thing in all of these stories
but by female sacrifice we can literally
mean like sacrificing their lives like
in this film where this woman risks her
life in the midst of like this storm
mudslide chaos scene all in the name of
saving these sheep that were sent to her
community by the government
or in this film song of retrospection
where the main character uses grenades
to blow herself up so that she can
destroy the oncoming South Korean
enemies to save the rest of her Squad
dumb team
using all these principles Kim Jong-il
ran the film studio he created dozens of
films that were his best shot at telling
good stories but really mostly
propaganda for his family's political
agenda to keep control over his people
and it worked Kim jong-il's dad stayed
in power the people stayed subservient
and indoctrinated to this fantasy of
Eternal Revolution and the glorification
of struggle and zhangil got to make
movies but despite all of this success
there was still one major problem
the film still kind of sucked and
jung-il the guy with a collection of 20
000 movies that he watched all the time
kind of knew that they sucked I mean of
course they sucked his filmmakers
weren't allowed to watch foreign movies
oh not to mention that they weren't even
allowed to leave the country so yeah
these films were kind of just in an echo
chamber of predictable characters
lackluster cinematography and the same
plots over and over with a bunch of
shoehorned like poetry and operas like
music breaks they weren't good and Jung
IL knew it his solution steal people
from the outside who could make his
films better
foreign
so it's the 1970s and Choi unhi is one
of South Korea's most popular actresses
she had been married to this South
Korean director shinseng AK and they had
recently divorced but up north Kim
Jong-il is looking at these two as the
potential solution to his problem so he
has his men go to Hong Kong and pose his
businessmen apparently interested in
starting a production company with Choi
they lure her to Hong Kong for a meeting
and this is how she got grabbed off a
beach at repulse Bay she gets sedated
thrown into the boat and they take her
back to North Korea where they put her
in a government building in Pyongyang
few weeks later her ex-husband the
director Shin goes to Hong Kong to look
for her he's in his car and suddenly the
car in front of him stops blocking the
road and forcing him to stop a few men
get out of the car come back and open
Shin's door and put a nylon bag over his
head the tire rope around his ankles and
they take him into their car he too is
now on his way to North Korea Kim
Jong-il greets Shin when he arrives to
Pyongyang and he explains what he's up
to he wants him and his actress ex-wife
to make him propaganda movies but Shin
refuses sir zhangil sends him to a labor
camp for five years okay so fast forward
to 1983. Kim Jong-il decides that the
two are finally enlightened whatever
that means and he throws them a party
and tells them that yes they're still
prisoners but they can make whatever
movie they want even apparently like
apologized and shifted the blame of like
the whole labor camp thing to like other
officials and said that he was too busy
to notice how poorly they were being
treated like this guy sounds literally
insane they don't really have much
Choice here so they get to work and over
the course of their years in captivity
they made six movies for their captor
one of the films that Shin directed
became a classic and this is the film
I'm like most excited to show you this
is pulgasari
this film seems to be a ripoff of a 1962
South Korean film called bulgasari which
was largely inspired by the Japanese hit
Godzilla we all know Godzilla we'll
never actually know because the
bulgasari South Korean film was
apparently lost soon after it was
released anyway the point is Kim Jong-il
wanted a monster movie he wanted this to
be so good that he even broke his rule
of not letting Outsiders come in to work
on his movies so in addition to the
stolen director that he had already
kidnapped he started recruiting the
people who worked on the Return of
Godzilla a year earlier over in Japan
including the actual guy who was in the
Godzilla suit as well as the man who led
the special effects like he had like the
Dream Team oh and of course to get them
there he lied according to the guy who
played Godzilla he and his crew were
told that they were heading to China for
a shoot and instead found themselves in
North Korea okay so now Zhang il's
lifelong movie fantasies are in reach
maybe just maybe North Korea could make
like an international Blockbuster he's
got his kidnapped director and all these
technicians to make his monster movie
great
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah no this didn't work out Kim Jong-il
was still overseeing the whole thing so
the film still was like full-blown
propaganda employing all of the North
Korean cinematic tricks that jungle laid
out in his book so of course you've got
the requisite juche self-reliance scene
showing the villagers getting water from
a well and farming gotta show that got
the overarching plot that outside help
AKA polgasari does more harm than good
more on that in a second and then
there's the requisite female sacrifice
when this blacksmith's daughter hides
inside of a bell so that pogasari who
eats metal will eat the bell and
simultaneously eat her and if she dies
then hogasari dies too because they like
formed this like blood bond in the
beginning of the movie it's a whole
thing
all right
anyway pogassari himself is said to be a
manifestation of capitalism in society
the farmers love him at first because he
helps overthrow the king all in the name
of promising these people individual
freedom but then they find that they've
created a monster who needs to feed on
steel and iron to grow more and more
powerful and it gets out of control so
the farmers just keep feeding him and
feeding him with all their Farming tools
but then they have no way to sustain
themselves so the only thing they can do
is stop the beast from growing which
means killing him meaning Revolution but
and this is where it gets really juicy
there's another way to interpret the
film remember who's directing it this
kidnapped South Korean director some
speculate that the director used the
film to create an analogy for the
tragedy of North Korea where Kim il-sung
who at first was helping liberate his
people from oppression and occupation
turned Power hungry ended up starving
the people demanding their resources
using the revolution to feed only
himself Shin the director later said
that the film was an anti-war
anti-authoritarian theme so take it
however you like I mean
this film's wild but in Kim jong-il's
eyes this was a massive success and Kim
Jong-il was feeling good and he let up a
bit on shin and Choi allowing them to
travel to Vienna for a film festival
where they could maybe meet a financing
partner who could bankroll a new project
a North Korean film on Genghis Khan but
of course when they got to Vienna they
found their way to the U.S embassy and
got asylum in the United States of
course Kim Jong-il was enraged when he
found out about this he actually went
back and took Shin's name off of all the
films that he had directed and ordered a
nationwide mandate to discredit him he
called Shin a traitor and his name has
become unmentionable without punishment
in North Korea
so yeah that is the Bonkers story of
North Korean Cinema in 1994 jong-il's
dad died and he eventually Rose as the
new supreme leader of North Korea his
love for movies continued to influence
the form of North Korean propaganda and
they even started an International Film
Festival in Pyongyang and the only
people on the invite list were like all
the countries that North Korea vibed
with like Iran Egypt India Vietnam and
China oh but this wasn't just during the
Cold War the festival was still going up
until the pandemic a few years ago it's
one of the few North Korean functions
that actively seeks connection to the
outside world
Kim Jong-il died in 2011 but his legacy
in North Korean Cinema remains super
strong one of the most recent films that
we know about came out in 2016
and it's the same old ingredients female
sacrifice extreme nationalism
unwarranted praise for the current
leader Kim Jong-un and of course no
shortage of spontaneous song breaks
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey everyone hope you enjoyed this video
I Know It was kind of long and in-depth
but boy we could not stop ourselves
there was too much here and there's so
much more that we couldn't include one
of my favorite kind of video lately is
where we go super deep into like some
Niche that I would never think to go
deep into but you start to pull on a
thread and you just can't get enough and
that's what happened in this case so I
hope you enjoyed it um let me show you
something hold on
I made a poster look
I've never made a poster before I
finally made a poster it's one I've been
wanting to make for a very long time
it's called all maps are wrong
because they are all maps are wrong in a
sense
um we're trying to you know take this
spherical Earth and put it on a flat
piece of paper and to do that we have to
stretch it in all these weird ways and
this map kind of celebrates that and
reminds us of it and turns it into kind
of art but it's like smart art yeah
smart art we'll call it the fact is uh
this is a way that you can support our
Channel if you're interested in that and
also get this wonderful poster you can
see the link in the description for
where to go find this poster The
Newsroom is our patreon community where
we publish an extra video every month
too you also get access to a bunch of
other perks that you can check out over
at patreon.com Johnny Harris Luts and
presets is what we use to color our
videos and photos uh this helps us make
our photos and videos look more
beautiful I started a travel company a
few years ago it's called bright trip
and it is a place where you go to get
smarter about traveling and to travel in
a smarter way and that's basically it
for me of all the things I have going on
that I wanted to tell you about
um thanks for being here and for
supporting the work that we do just by
being here and commenting and being a
part of this discussion I really value
this community and excited to keep
making stuff
see you in the next one
[Music]